[Music]
all right we have an update on a new
york photographer who went viral for her
photos of children dressed up as civil
rights icons well now trisha mezarow is
putting together a new book that
features young girls who embody female
trailblazers it includes everyone from
maya angelou to beyonce to ruth bader
ginsburg we found out how these powerful
images are inspiring the next generation
of leaders
give me big give me big yep right there
excellent there we go
yep that's good good good they're
stepping into the lives of legends relax
that shoulder down
just like that tilt your head
just like that right there the way they
looked hello i'm stacey abrams the way
they talk hola
so that's how you found out about serene
williams tricia messero is the
mastermind of toddlewood trailblaze her
young girls imitating giants downsized
to fit in a book that chronicles their
achievements these young ladies they're
dreamers they've got big dreams they
know what they want to do in life and
they know that they can get there but
when they hear
the stories of the women who came before
them and what they did it gives them the
can-do attitude
ten-year-old nya otero had big shoes to
fill as misty copeland who not only
broke racial barriers
but forever altered the traditional
ballerina ideal
misty copeland to me is a really great
role model
me a girl of color and a proud latina
she inspires me and many of the girls
like me to pursue our passions and be of
excellence in everything that we do oh
my god it's a role copeland gladly
embraces remembering those who lifted
her up as a teenager at the boys and
girls club it is a beautiful
responsibility that i accept it just
makes sense to me because of the
guidance and the examples that have been
set for me
there's no way i can continue on and not
speak up and not help to motivate and
guide the next generation including
aspiring dancers like otero got it i am
the queen of salsa celia cruz
nine-year-old jaylee rosemarie supre was
cast as celia cruz
cuban-american singer who tackled gender
and color barriers head-on i see celia
cruising me you see celia cruising you
the laugh the hand gestures everything i
automatically like fell in love with her
and i felt like a connection
thirteen-year-old bailey park dressed up
as fashion designer vera wang it's
honestly super amazing to see another
asian that impacted the world so greatly
eleven-year-old chloe vieira assumed the
role of supreme court justice ruth bader
ginsburg only the second woman on the
u.s supreme court the really inspiring
part is that we had these amazing people
to impact and like hey that's not fair
why don't we do this we should we should
start rallies and we should
we should just fight for our rights is
this a book that's just for girls boys
read it they think maybe i should treat
girls a little bit better because you
know they've impacted the world so much
there's so many so many inspiring women
we should start thinking more about them
start appreciating them more still i
rise by my angels you may write me down
the history a newfound appreciation that
even seven-year-old madison klein
acknowledged and this heartfelt note to
photographer tricia messero thank you
for choosing me to be mini maya angelou
i learned so much about going after my
dreams and not letting anything stop me
sometimes
you might doubt yourself but you
shouldn't because if all those role
models can do anything you can do the
same as them
still you rise yes still we rise yes
they'll always rise
oh man they were so adorable i enjoyed
that shoot uh tremendously i took my
daughter with me she kind of was feeling
some sort of way like i want to be in
this mom well i was going to say would
you have a would you have a selection
for journey
you know she was actually ruth bader
ginsburg
last year halloween yes
um but honestly i think there's nothing
like showing
children girls what they can be and also
paying homage to the people before them
so that they know it's possible and you
always come back for them is the
greatest motivating fact that they can
have and just to be clear you're saying
that's a book not only for girls oh no
because it helps the boys know how to
talk to us and respect us as you just
heard the young girls say that